thank you Joe I would like to start
thanking David and Yale University for
giving us a platform to reflect on the
Wonder
speaking of the legacies of the genocide
against Tutsi in the wonder it's
important to remember that 19 years ago
actually soon to be 20 years ago Rwanda
was a failed nation he walked around the
streets from the south to the north east
to the west was a pile of bad dead
bodies
women children elders London's mostly of
Tutsi ethnic group but also of who to
admit II who betrayed their fellow who
to for simply opposing the anti-treaty
propaganda so when we reflect on the
legacies of the genocide in the war now
it's important to realize they challenge
the indescribable amount that we had to
claim to come back on earth because then
the entire nation had sank in this
genocidal pit as a nation it was a
challenge to pick and choose our
priorities when we're talking about
London's killing do one dance wives
tanning against their husbands husbands
turning against their children because
they looked like their mothers and they
did no longer trust that they were their
own
skilling was so intimate killing was so
calm you know killing was so patriotic
that we just couldn't afford to ask for
justice as we know it you learned about
catracha katachi came not because was
the best judicial system but because
looking at thousands and thousands and
millions moon of New Orleans who had
participated in the killings either by
picking up machetes or finger pointing
to where to the X was hiding or to
screaming enough to scare a little girl
like me and Casa ray to come out of our
hiding places
killing was involved almost everyone and
except those who were targeted and some
of them were involved
not by will but by force because was an
act led by the government so how do you
approach justice and how do you do it in
a way that you can bring a nation back
together you can bring the motion back
on its fruit in the way that it can
start making steps forward that's a
challenge and I don't think any of us
would really have an answer and I
remember I was about 20 when this you
know gotcha
discussion was at the highest peak and
having been an active survivor since the
genocide happened trying to be the voice
for those who could no longer speak or
for those away no longer I remember
sitting in that room as as a human
rights activist under the umbrella of
craddle we were discussing how can we
tackle these issues how can we we were
looking at the cost of keeping all these
London's in the prisons that way fully
packed yet half of their Janice Adele or
they presume Janice Adela we're not even
in jail but yet I was still feeling the
pain of not even knowing whether it
means of my father in my four siblings
way just like every other other survivor
in the room and what do you do and I
remember it was not until it was
mentioned that maybe the money that we
are using again remember we were left as
a nation with no friends we could dare
telling us that there were our friends
after going what going through what who
went through in the eye of the
international community idly watching Oh
actually intervening not to help
survivors but the genocidal into the
refugee camps in the Congo and that
doesn't of course we talked about the
lack of intervention but sometimes we
don't mention that the French
authorities intervened they were in
Rwanda before 1994 they fought alongside
the forces of dead the same urgency that
regime and they came back with the
blessing of the international community
that you add and when they came back I
met them because I lived in their zone
two quads and I'm gonna tell you and
remind you that they did not come to
save me because they did not save me if
they did who did not we wouldn't be
discussing or we wouldn't be laboring
one of the worst killing sites in the
entire nation was Becerra a place where
more than fifty thousand one and two
things and moderate Hutu were killed in
the watch of French soldiers after
French came they mobilized us and made
us believe that they were there to
protect us yet for me we was moving
among the killers through that corridor
I'm here to tell you that
we tequilas since I was disguised among
them moved under that safe zone with our
grenades and most of us crossed into
Congo and this is why we're still
talking about the crisis in the Congo at
least one of the reasons we still
looking at the Congo so the legacies of
the genocide in Rwanda has perfect us as
London's tomorrow the effect if we fail
ourselves if we fail our nation we are
gone we have learned that slowly but
surely we have to build that political
muscle that economic muscle and to be
able to do that we have to do it in a
way that everyone and it's a part of
that muscle because we remain a tiny
little country with no diamonds and
goals but we want our minds we want our
spirit of never giving up so they they
are gold that we give to the world and
we want this spirit to transpire even
through those who once were called
killers that's how we learned to forgive
and to forgive we had to start by
forgiving our own selves because when
you survived that tragedy you survive
with the guilt the guilt of being when
the minion is no longer the guild of
surviving when your your your for those
who were parents when your entire family
was wiped off you feel so important as a
man because you could know to protect
your kids but you have to forgive
yourself
if you have to leave to forgive anyone
else and we have miraculously done it
but to be able to do it it takes
leadership you took leadership by the
way to organize the killings in the last
20 years he has taken been one and
leadership to move Rwanda beyond the
deadly peat with a determination of no
longer going back and to be able to do
that we the survivors had had
so give much more than we could afford
despite the pain that came with that
forgiveness we forgave before the pardon
was asked for but because we needed it
even for us to pick up our pieces and
move forward and there have been so many
higher grantsolutions we talk about
reconciliation as if it was just like
one box that everyone and went through
no it was multi-dimensional he was done
in action it was done in schools it was
done in hospitals you can't really talk
about reconciliation if you sell gonna
favor one side over the other if your
kid can go to school and mine can't or
we can go to school but I can get a job
and you can't we have to create a system
and you have managed to create a system
where everyone at the elementary school
level is at this moment enrolled in
school yet we did that after all the
schools were demolished and every money
we had was taken into Congo for those
who were exiting the country so we have
looked inward we looked we heard about
that structure for the success of gotcha
really being the most comprehensive I
remember it was very painful for us to
even accept that we cannot we cannot
punish those who did wrong but rather
let's find a system where they're gonna
feel like they can be a part of this new
Wanda and they can move with us and it
was imaginable at the beginning but by
doing it we gained when the survivors
were able to find the remains of our own
people and that's the biggest justice
you can give me that's the only way I
actually came to accept that my first
siblings and my father and all my
grandparents and in the end and the more
than 100 people from my own family in
the minion were gone it is by going to
those pits where the bodies were piled
up and picking up pieces and recognizing
certain things when finding a bracelet
like this that was won by my grandmother
for the last 19 years
and finding it and cleansing to that
hope but now that you bury them now that
you restore their dignity you can move
on but for that to be you move on and go
where because there were no home so it's
very creating the economic system where
little by little more people can get
jobs you know by little more people can
have and see to play the future that we
all trying to forge and 20 as we are
here we are a celebration we talk about
a nearly universal health care system in
the nation like Myranda where the u.s.
one of the most powerful nation does not
have that you have malaria you have a
place to go no matter who you are you
are at X level to be in school and less
than a memory school we have reached
girls and boys parity but you also heard
about women empowerment women
empowerment sometimes people feel but of
course many men were God why because you
know the target obviously was we are
primarily meant first because the main
way regarded as the heads of every every
household you know and most women who
remained the records public record said
that more than 175 thousand women were
raped I have to tell you it's much
higher than that number so what do you
do in a nation where you have close to
360,000 survivors in the nation we're
primarily female what do you do how do
you it's not so much mercy it's not so
much the government policy that has
energized all these women to actually
occupied all these high places they're
in now leaving the changes that we're
talking about that we here to celebrate
it is really because women coming back
to Park in every nation to the history
women have always been DUIs but then
their their productivity was never
attributed to them and
for once we have leaders like our own
president who was raised himself by his
own mother I think he came from his own
personal experience he has managed to to
to lead randoms in cherishing women
because he has cherished he cherishes
his own mother his own mother who looked
after him since age 2 in those refugee
camps and little by little we changed
the constitution we created an
environment where women have access to
every opportunity you can imagine we did
not have entitlement to land now we do
we are just as empowered as our main
counterparts so I can go on but I know
you wouldn't allow the time is so
limited I want to bring us back to why
we're here quit baka means to remember
as David said but if we have to remember
and just leave it there I don't think
it's necessary that we do remember let
this memory be a source of endless
energy for us to actually come together
Brandon's despite all the challenges
have come together I look at my Hutu
countrymen I don't have any any hatred
anymore but it took it was a process and
really it took some leadership it took
people could see further than I could
it could people could see beyond their
own personal losses and pain and say if
Banda has to come together we're going
to have to make sacrifices and
sacrifices have to be led by the
survivors it was so hard to swallow at
the beginning but now we celebrate not
just the 20th we can no longer let
genocide define us because we were much
bigger than genocide we are much as a
nation you hear I'm from Rwanda Oh Hotel
Rwanda the terrible genocide that's true
we are here to recognize that that
history was our
but we also want the world to know that
we have contributed a lot starting with
our own you know unimaginable spirit the
resilience that has taken do one dance
not just in high places like the UN
Security Council where I will remain a
very active member
not in places like Haiti in South Sudan
in Central African Republic where we
will remain the most involved
changemakers through the peacekeeping
operations you know but we see ourselves
as still struggling nation economically
but a nation with the vision and the
nation that calls upon you today and
going forward to make sure that never
again that we failed 20 years ago is
something that we can make a reality and
you are ready to work with you we are
not just standing by as victims because
we have more than we can proclaim and
the stewardship of peacemakers is what
we flag as a flag I thank you
you